while you might think a movie called
freelance is about someone trying to set
up a side hustle renting out their
garage or something it's actually a big
time action comedy starring John Cena
and if you've been paying attention to
Cena over the last few years you know
that action and comedy are two things he
does like really well so it's no
surprise he signed on to freelance the
movie arrives soon so we thought we'd
dive into everything we know so far
about this upcoming popcorn flick since
the movie isn't out yet we don't know a
ton about the nitty-gritty of the plot
not that you'd want any spoilers anyway
right but so far we can get some Basics
from the trailer John Cena's character
is no surprise a badass and not just
like a regular one a former Special
Forces type of badass but things have
changed a lot since his day is kicking
butt and taking names in the military
when the movie starts we find Mason
having settled down into Suburbia he's
got a wife kids and a pretty
straightforward lawyer job that he's
apparently pretty B B doing while there
isn't a white picket fence in the
trailer we're Assuming he's got one of
those too just what he thinks his life
is destined to be a cookie cutter Bland
version of what it used to be he gets a
call from a friend offering him some
cash to help out with a bodyguard type
gig it's a one-off thing and he's going
to get a nice little payday he'll
accompany a journalist to a South
American country where she'll interview
their president and while it's
supposedly a dangerous country hence the
need for a journalist to have a
bodyguard it's seems like it'll be an
easy mission for Mason plus a nice
payout of course if you're familiar with
you know movies you won't be surprised
to find out that things don't go as
planned a major military coup happens as
they're traveling with the president
Mason the journalist and the president
form an unlikely Trio as they try to
stay alive and perhaps get the country
back in order and of course since it's
an action flick there will be a lot of
fighting shooting wrestling and grunting
and some wild explosions John Cena ising
doing the literal heavy lifting in
freelance and probably was number one on
the call sheet but it also seems like a
pretty solid two-hander aka the other
lead is vital to the plot and
contributes just as much the insanely
talented and funny Allison Brie plays
the journalist Claire Wellington Bri has
built a career out of being able to
Traverse both comedy and drama most
people know her from her role in the
sitcom Community or as the lead in the
widely loved Netflix show glow but she's
also shined in heavy dramas like horse
girl an intense drama she wrote and
starded the third lead Juan Pablo Raba
is a relative unknown to many audiences
he plays President Venegas the leader of
the fictional country of palonia now if
you're Colombian or have watched a lot
of telenovellas and Spanish language
Productions you might be pretty familiar
with him he's a Colombian model and
actor who has worked a lot but American
audiences likely would only know him
from his Arc as Gustavo Gava in narcos
Raba isn't isn't exactly known for being
a comedic actor but by the looks of the
trailer he's contributing in a big way
to the levity and fun of this movie he
seems to have an attraction to both Bri
and Cena's characters which will likely
bring a lot of funny and entertaining
moments to the flick of course that's
assuming Cena's character manages to
keep the three of them safe throughout
the major coup happening all around them
while it isn't too much of an ensemble
movie Beyond those main three characters
it does have a couple fun cameos
Christian Slater plays Mason's friend
the one who recruits him to take the
freelance security gig in the first
place it's unclear how much of a role he
has beyond that initial scene but
hopefully he's in it more any
Christian's Slater appearance makes a
scene better in our humble opinion it
also has Alice Eve as Mason's wife she's
a familiar face to many having starred
in a variety of movies over the years
like Men in Black 3 She's Out of My
League and Star Trek Into Darkness one
of the appealing things about free
freance is that both Cena and Bri and
seemingly Roba too are actors who are
able to be free on screen they always
appear to put the movie and their
characters first and not worry as much
about looking cool or tough as such they
can actually be both tough and funny and
that potentially serves an action comedy
really well freelance features an
interesting combo of straightup Comedy
writer with a straightup action director
Jacob lent wrote the script and while
it's his first feature film he wrote on
more than a, episodes yep you heard that
right of Jimmy Kimel live so he's
clearly a qualified person to bring the
comedy into this action comedy and the
director Pierre Morel has had a hand in
some pretty epic action movies he's
about seven films into his directing
career with one of his notable films
being the alltime great taken so clearly
he's a qualified person to bring the
action part of this action comedy the
production actually filmed in Colombia
which adds authenticity to the movie
it's based in a fictional land called
palonia but but it's meant to be in a
country very similar to Colombia so it's
pretty cool to see that the whole thing
wasn't done on a sound stage in Los
Angeles the jungles in the trailer are
actual Colombian jungles finally
freelance hits theaters and theaters
only on October 27th no word yet on when
it'll be available to purchase at home
or stream though the pairing of Cena and
Bri is definitely going to be awesome
and I can't wait to grab a bucket of
popcorn and spend a couple hours in the
jungles of palonia with those two have
any thoughts about this upcoming action
comedy pop them in the comments section